[Music]
on this Saturday night a global news
exclusive with Ukraine's top negotiator
his thoughts on China's peace plan all
wars eventually and with on the
negotiation table and his timeline for
victory one year into the war
did Ottawa ignore warnings about an MP
allegedly backed by Beijing the former
head of Canada's spy agency reacts to a
global news investigation
it snowed in Hollywood and I made a
snowball and the extraordinary storm
paralyzing parts of the U.S
global national with Fara Nasser
good evening and thank you for joining
us
it has now been a year since Russia
invaded Ukraine and in that time life
has changed indefinitely there
once beautiful bustling towns and cities
now battered and broken by Russian
shelling for millions of people everyday
life has turned horrifying and miserable
people have been returning to What's
Left of their favorite places like
schools clinging tip any piece of
normalcy and then there are historic
landmarks like this theater in Mary
Apple damage after Russian airstrikes
hit
but it's really here at Mass Graves like
this where we see the real cost of the
war the United Nations says there have
been more than 21 000 civilian
casualties in Ukraine since the war
started that includes more than 8 000
who have been killed and more than 13
000 who have been injured
the Russian invasion started as a
full-scale attack throughout different
areas of its Western neighbor Ukraine
has reclaimed much of the captured land
but Russia still controls Parts in the
South and the East much of it territory
it illegally annexed last year but the
war continues with no clear signs of an
ending
joining us now in a Canadian television
exclusive interview is Ukraine's Chief
negotiator in this Warren leader of
Vladimir zielinski's servant of the
people party David arahamiya thank you
for being with us Mr arahamiya you're a
close advisor to the president you've
been with him since day one how have you
changed this past year and how has he
changed
that's a good question thank you I think
I did not change at least I'm not seeing
myself changed a lot as for zelenski he
became I think he became less
patient in terms of you know like before
every time that something bad happens so
if you try to analyze and you know ask
everybody interrogate what happened and
how we could avoid it in the future now
he has no more time for this so if the
person fails he just like puts him out
of the team immediately second thing I
think emotionally he also like became
kind of a harder person now because he
saw so many you know uh bad things
happened around him you know like it was
the Ukrainian people so he kind of
became tougher now China has come up
with a proposed peace plan on the
anniversary do you think it could lead
anywhere
well the good sign is China started to
feel that they also need to participate
in some kind of you know mitigation of
the war because before if you took a
look for a year they tried to pretend
that nothing happened
so it's a good sign that in their ideas
or concepts they saying that we have to
obey United Nations
statutes which uh you know which has to
respect the the legal borders of the
country so it plays for us
is that that sign I think is that there
was no single word about uh a call to
Russian troops to go back
behind our borders so it's acceptable
for us but we should consider China I
think because it's so big and powerful
it remains uh kind of a neutral so the
the so far we have no evidence that they
are supporting Russia with weapons or
you know special military technologists
we just like need to to talk to them and
uh see if their intentions are really
serious or those intentions are just
politics
what gives you hope right now
my hope that our counter-offensive
operation
in the summer I think it will come the
summer maybe early early autumn will be
successful and will give a very very
clear signal to Russians so to sit down
and sign the deal on our terms This Is
My Hope
do you think you'll be sitting down at
the negotiating table again
well you know like diplomats I'm not a
professional Diplomat you know like but
I got so many advisors on this you know
like I talked to so many people around
the world and everybody is saying that
all wars eventually end with uh on the
negotiation table
so whatever you know War it is whatever
scale it is it always end up in the same
place you know like so that's why it's
inevitable
David thank you so much for your time
it's a little bit likewise thank you
very much
one year into the war and Canada has
shown its support for Ukraine is as
strong if not stronger than it was 365
days ago
but while the federal government has
approved more than half a million
applications through a specialized
program for ukrainians less than a third
have actually arrived here in the last
13 months
while thousands of ukrainians wait to
make their way into our country Canada
is showing Ukraine we're ready with open
arms Mike troulet reports
on a bitterly cold day in Winnipeg
marching through the streets is the last
thing anybody wanted to do
[Applause]
[Music]
but how could this mix of ukrainians and
their supporters not gather on the
one-year anniversary of the Russian
invasion what can we do we just support
each other
pray together
we we celebrate our freedom vigils were
held in a 41 Canadian cities Friday
night they were large and mostly hopeful
I wish that this war
end
in the nearest field ship in Toronto an
anti-trudeau Heckler trying to ruin the
moment instead delivered an opportunity
for the prime minister to Rally the
crowd sir I think ukrainians can tell
you a little bit about freedom of
Liberty
the night for them none for you the
Ukrainian supporters cheered but it was
bittersweet so many lives have either
been lost or upended we're all living in
this trauma Arena kuznetsova who has
lived in Vancouver for nine years says
they have survivors guilt her family
hailed from ameripole a city that is now
unrecognizable her parents weren't able
to get out before the bombs fell her
mother who had terminal cancer dug her
own husband's grave her mother
eventually arrived in Vancouver only to
die a few months later now Arena's goal
is to make sure the world doesn't turn
its back it's been surreal since
kind of watching the school bully go and
you know take stuff and teachers
watching and doing nothing but
fortunately she says Canada so far is
living up to its commitments of
providing a safe haven to ukrainians
fleeing what has been a year-long
nightmare microwave Global News Toronto
and in Ukraine hospitals continue to be
unsafe and have been under a constant
barrage of Rocket fire since the War
Began a new report out this week shows
that one year later the Ukrainian Health
Care system is on the brink Catherine
Ward reports on the repeated calls for
Russia to be held accountable
hospitals destroyed
workers under stress
and a system fighting against the odds
hospitals have been attacked multiple
times a new report reveals the scope of
Russian attacks specifically on Health
Care between February and December of
last year researchers documented more
than 700 attacks on the system including
292 attacks on 218 hospitals 181 on
other health care infrastructure
including pharmacies and research
centers 65 documented attacks on
ambulances 86 on health care workers
including 62 people who died experts say
these numbers keep Rising making it
increasingly difficult to give basic
care the tax on health so fear and
Terror in civilian populations they also
make it more difficult for civilian
populations to access important
medicines vaccinations care for chronic
conditions with the health care crisis
now reaching every corner of the country
sometimes even when hospitals had this
cross on hospital and it was visible
from from the air that it was a hospital
but still it was attacked so today we
have one of three ukrainians that don't
have access to Medicine in Ukraine
Ukrainian Canadians like Gabriella
bunchek say needs are great and supplies
are running thin one truck with 24
pallets of bandages we used that
extremely economically but it goes in
one week still there is commitment and a
drive to keep going the ukrainians are
inspiring organizations around the world
you know with the uh not Optimist but
kind of like willingness to fight to the
end and the world is inspiring
ukrainians basically by helping us
we are getting the message from the
world that the world is nothing
different Advocates are calling on the
International Community to ensure Russia
is held responsible prioritize these
these attacks for further investigation
and prosecution and to build cases that
can can ultimately result in
accountability uh for for these
violations Catherine Ward Global News
Toronto
AS Global News first reported yesterday
there are new allegations from
intelligent sources that a sitting
liberal MP is affiliated with China's
attempts to meddle in Canada's democracy
this weekend on the west block host
Mercedes Stevenson explores what this
means for Canada's security and she
joins us now with more on the MP in
question Mercedes
Farah new allegations from intelligent
sources that a sitting liberal Member of
Parliament is a winning affiliate of the
Chinese government's attempts to
interfere in Canada's democracy is
renewing concerns over foreign meddling
in Canada's 2019 and 2021 elections the
politician in question liberal MP Han
dong has denied the allegation and the
Prime Minister Justin Trudeau's office
has refused to acknowledge whether
senior officials in the pmo were warned
by ceases as sources have alleged to
Global News while the Prime Minister has
acknowledged foreign interference is a
serious concern he has dismissed recent
media leaks as quote inaccurate and
assured Canadians of the Integrity of
the recent election but despite these
dismissals calls are growing louder for
a public investigation this week on the
west block former director of cesus and
the National Security adviser to the
Prime Minister dick Fadden says that
while the overall outcome of Canada's
elections have been quote absolutely
legitimate it is time for a public
inquiry to get the truth about what
China may have been up to
the allegations are so serious they need
to be looked into so the question is if
you don't do a public inquiry who does
it I think the logical place would be
Parliament but it has become so partisan
that I think that this particular kind
of topic would be almost impossible for
them to look at objectively so I think a
public inquiry is really the route to go
in addition to a public inquiry Fadden
said he would like to see political
parties take responsibility to ensure
that the elections Act is being followed
Mr Trudeau has dismissed some of the
concerns around foreign election
interference as partisan but even if the
Prime Minister did launch immediate
action Fadden says there is no quick
solution there's no Silver Bullet this
is going to take some effort dealing
with social media and some of the ethnic
press is going to take time but I think
the first thing we need to do is to talk
about this seriously the West block also
spoke with former conservative MP Kenny
Chu who said that he experienced China's
meddling in Canadian democracy firsthand
blaming Beijing as a fact doctor in
losing his seat she says government
action on the issue is long overdue
we'll have more on that story plus
defense minister Anita Anand is on the
show to discuss Canada's newest pledge
for Military Support to Ukraine and what
it will mean for the Canadian Armed
Forces pharah okay Mercedes Stevenson in
Ottawa thank you Mercedes and you can
watch the full interview with the former
director of Canada's security
intelligence service tomorrow morning on
the west block right here on global
California's deep freeze coming up the
Golden State hit with blizzard warnings
as rare winter weather fuels a monster
snowstorm plus uniting Ukraine the
critical Railway Network keeping cargo
Aid and people moving despite constant
Russian attacks
[Music]
tonight people on Canada's West Coast
are being told to hunker down and avoid
travel with some heavy snow in the mix
across the border another powerful
winter storm is already pummeling the
Western U.S prompting blizzard and
Avalanche warnings there's frigid
conditions flash flooding and snow
blanketing Southern California as ready
chiquini reports the unusual and
extraordinary cold snap is being labeled
historic and hazardous it's not out of
the ordinary to see a near White out
blizzard in February the issue here this
part of the United States rarely ever
experiences a real winter it snowed in
Hollywood and I made a snowball yet
another storm carrying cold Canadian Air
rushed in over Southern California
spawning almost unheard of blizzard
warnings and closing parts of the main
Interstate connecting LA and San
Francisco even at the higher elevations
away from ski country 15 centimeters to
nearly a meter of snow is a near once in
a lifetime event Mountains they're
usually just Brown
a few green things never white down at
sea level it is far more concerning
rainfall has the Los Angeles River
raging 30 minutes West in Valencia three
motorhomes were Swept Away in the Santa
Clara River and well 6 million
Californians are under a flood warning
there is a silver lining the biggest Pro
is that we're getting above normal in
our precipitation California just
experienced one of its worst drought
years on record and a month of non-stop
storms could ease the stress a huge
deficit that's many years old meanwhile
the cleanup continues from this
seemingly unending season that's left
its mark across Oregon and in Michigan
where days after a historic ice storm
hundreds of thousands remain in the dark
we expect the vast majority back by the
end of the day Sunday even California's
famed at Napa Valley which averages zero
centimeters of snow hasn't escaped the
cruel grip of a winter that won't let up
Reggie Global News
ahead Fighting For Truth Canada's
efforts to counter Russian
disinformation distorting what's really
happening in Ukraine
[Music]
the old saying goes knowing is half the
battle and when it comes to Russia's
invasion of Ukraine one factor
influencing Canadians attitudes toward
it is the ability to get reliable
information but in the age of social
media and online disinformation that's
easier said than done now global news
has obtained internal Federal polling
which shows that the prime minister's
office is taking interest in how
disinformation campaigns are affecting
Canadians views of this conflict our
David Aiken has the details
long before Russian tanks rolled into
Ukraine a year ago Russia had started a
campaign of what we now know as
disinformation the disinformation that
that Russia is promoting amplifying on
social media and on their state media
platforms is um is directly intended to
erode Western and Canadian public
support for Ukraine last October the
Trudeau cabinet wanted to know how
disinformation was affecting the ability
of Canadians to tell fact from fiction
through an access to information request
Global News has learned that as part of
the weekly internal polling program
overseen by the pmo Canadians were asked
what impact do you think disinformation
is having on Canadians ability to tell
the difference between true and false
information about the conflict 37
percent said it is having a major impact
35 percent said it was having a minor
impact while just 17 percent said no
impact I hope that the government looks
at these numbers and hasn't uh can can
clearly see that this is a this is a
significant problem and that even
Canadians regular Canadians are
recognizing it as such
opposition MP say the Trudeau government
needs to act on the data it collected
this disinformation campaign is
undermining our own democracy and this
information campaign is hurting Western
support in prime minister Justin Trudeau
said Friday his government would do more
we will continue to support Brave
journalists who are telling the truth
who are sharing actual news and facts
around the world
we will continue to ensure that there is
no place for the lies that Putin is
sharing for now though the most visible
part of Canada's campaign to counter
disinformation consists of this
two-month-old Government website that
fact checks false Russian claims David
Akin Global News
Ottawa
next Ukraine's iron Brotherhood how the
country's rail system is giving the
economy and war effort some extra Steam
in the 12 months since Russia's invasion
of Ukraine Ukraine's rail system has
been a constant Lifeline keeping people
and cargo moving along with Aid through
some of the hardest hit wartime regions
the trains run despite repeated Russian
attacks on the Network's infrastructure
and tonight Mike Armstrong tells the
story of a carriage repair facility hit
by Russian missiles last summer and how
it's never been busier
imagine going to work each day at a
place that's already being bombed once
knowing it could happen again the head
of this rail Carriage repair plant says
employees took last Summer's attack as a
challenge
Yuri filipov says at first they thought
the plant was destroyed then they took a
deep breath and decided to work twice as
hard
June 5th Russian missiles hit four
buildings in the compound it was 5 a.m
the day shift hadn't started so only one
person was injured now Russia claimed
the attack targeted tanks and armored
vehicles but the head of the plant says
they only build and repair carriages for
grain and cargo now in the hours after
the attack other rail factories offered
cars tractors and trains to help rebuild
but there was also something he didn't
expect
he says civilians from the neighborhood
came out with Spades and shovels to help
as much as they could the plant was
reorganized and as it turns out improved
why keep growing and pushing the reason
he says is the desire to survive
seaport's blocked more grain and corn is
moved by train to European ports but the
head of the rail system says it's about
more than just the economy it's also
about morale we had to show that there
is at least something stable in the
country we never stopped the rail system
before the war was the country's biggest
employer well there are fewer right now
close to 10 000 left to join the
Ukrainian military
says some people fight in combat on the
front lines others fight on the economic
front but when the war is over he says
everyone will work together
to rebuild
Mike Armstrong Global News
and you can watch Mike Armstrong's full
story on Ukraine's Railway on the new
reality tonight at 7 right here on
global and then at 7 30 Global News will
Air a half hour special to mark one year
since the full-scale Russian invasion of
Ukraine
and that's global national for this
Saturday night I'm Farah Nasser and on
behalf of our whole crew I want to thank
you so much for spending part of your
Saturday evening with us tonight we
leave you with the scenes of solidarity
and support for Ukraine from Mexico to
Taiwan people all over the world are
standing together flying Ukrainian Flags
marking one year since Russia's invasion
until tomorrow take care of yourselves
and take care of each other
good night